n wonder is a [__] Encyclopedia of
hip-hop nice guy uh sway is too yeah
sway for sure is the only thing I don't
like about sway there's one thing I
don't like about
sway sway too nice man sway is too nice
he's too affable he's too approachable
he's too conciliatory is that that's a
negative it's not a negative but you
know a lot of people talk about all of
these people and these powerful people
and where they should be and one of the
stals one of the most important voices
sometimes I just want to sway the
comment under the [__] thing and say
[__] I'm your father I've been doing
this everyone's father I've been doing
this I agree but sway he's like
legitimately I'm walking through a um a
[__] um walking through a hotel 2014
2015 stopped hey man I love what you
this is way pre Kanye sto I love what
you doing TMZ and blah blah blah blah
approachable give you advice talk to
just a perfect energy and I just want
you know I'm here for and he's been yeah
a one year heel turn from sway I see I
don't I don't I think that's why we love
sway cuz he's above all that [__] he
is he's above like the petty [__] he's
above you know worrying about what other
people are doing it's true you know I
think like Elliot's been going through
that the last six months or so where
tough and I you know for me like seeing
like like Elliots to like up there with
sway in terms of like [__] I used to get
his magazines when I was a kid you know
what I mean I used to buy every double
XL and all the sources and everything
and so I think with Elliott it's like I
don't know it's like a mixed bag I guess
how people feel with him kind of like
kind of poking at you know like a kais
not or you know but sway I wouldn't want
I just feel like that's why sway sway is
the goat so it's like if sway's the goat
it's sway or Elliott but sway's the goat
on a whole different level in terms for
me cuz when I think of my childhood and
watching MTV that's where we before the
internet I watch sway interviews on MTV
News you know but I think that that's
why we love sway cuz sway is
above just you know that's here's the
thing about Elliot pocket watching
looking over at other people you know
this this is why I say about
Elliot um Elliott knows how how I feel
about him and what I think about him
about him and honestly what B do do and
what they mean you know they know how
important they are you know you could B
dot is not a guy that lacks in any type
of confidence this what I would say
about Elliot neither by the way neither
lacking any sort of confidence neither I
say about Elliot and I hope that this is
taken with as much love as why how I
mean it Elliot is supposed to remain the
example of what we want to be it will be
a gigantic blow to
hiphop into hip-hop
journalism if Elliot Wilson turns into
the example of what you don't want to be
and what you what you want to be like
he's the golden standard let me tell
yeah exactly so what you want to be Ag
and in every single different avenue
what you have to have are like you said
standard
Setters um Monument Builders mhm right
mhm Legends and authorities on stuff
yeah and when you're that when you are
that
that's bigger than a crowd that you can
pull or the heat that you can deliver
it's bigger because what it maintains is
the cultural Integrity of whatever
you're endeavoring into hip hop is a
more serious Endeavor because guys like
Elliot Wilson exist yeah hip hop is a
more serious art form because it has
serious critics and serious journalists
like Elliot Wilson if he devolves which
it seems like he's dead set trying to if
he devolves into this new school which
I'm not saying I'm not a part of of
clout chasing media Figures it's not
just a blow to Elliot Wilson's Legacy
it's blow to everything it's a blow to
all of it hip hop becomes less serious
if guys like that take themselves less
seriously yeah I I look at Elliott and
beat as like you know I I think back to
like sitting at my house I think it was
Christmas or New Year's a few years ago
watching the Drake interview and I'm
like this is the like these guys don't
have to put out a bunch of [__] because
when like they can have conversations
like that nobody else has the access to
have and or like that's why like when he
was kind of mad that Drake was doing
whatever Drake was doing sitting in the
bed with that what's that chick's name
the white chick uh Bobby Alto yeah yeah
like like it like it doesn't matter
because you got the three-hour all time
Drake interview and you're going to get
another one cuz you're [__] Elliot
Wilson but here's the deal though
there's a way to make that criticism
right right I I tell you what I mean by
that there's a way to legitimately I'm
not a part of hip-hop media oh [__] Kev
damn that velro came off wow bro things
are broken there it is [__] it on it's
always good to drop a white man on his
[__] head your head in there there go
boom there we go the [__] I'm talking
about um
so
uh ecosystems we talk about ecosystems
what is an ecosystem an ecosystem is
something that uh cyclical if he itself
right it's it's a system of Life MH so
that means that like um you know the
[__] plant grows the [__] insect
eats the plant the [__] animal eats
the insect animal dies ecosystem when
one part of the ecosystem stops working
the whole ecosystem is threatened right
it is incumbent upon hip-hop artists to
do interviews with hip-hop media because
that feeds the
ecosystem they have to do hip-hop media
there's no I'm telling you they if you
are a rap artist and you are a big rap
artist you have to do traditional
hip-hop media at some point in time no
or you think every cycle you have to do
it all the time and the reason why I
think you have to do it all the time is
two reasons number one cultural
responsibility to to to invest back into
that media number one by the way I don't
disagree with you and number two to feed
the ecosystem of hip-hop because the
other part of it the the people that
look like Bobby and all of those people
they going to eat off hip hop regard
the question isn't whether or not Bobby
alof is or whoever her name is and no
disrespect to her is going to eat off
hip hop that's not a question her people
going to eat off hip hop because her
people own the record companies her
people uh playlist the [__] they own the
big streamers they going to eat off hi
hop by the way I don't know who her
people are but well well I say her
people is I mean white so so her people
are going to eat off hip hop no matter
what the question is whether or
not the black people and not just black
but the people in hip-hop
media whether they're going to eat off
of it and the only way to really control
that is to go sit down with them right I
think that unfortunately most artists
don't agree with you anymore they don't
agree I'll tell you why they don't agree
they don't agree because and I this is
just a direct criticism because as hard
as they are they are equally [__] and I
say they equally [__] because every
want to be hip-hop but don't nobody want
to be hip-hop don't nobody want to sit
down and answer questions in the way
that hip hop interviewers ask them don't
nobody want to have somebody hip hop is
supposed to be this cultural art form
where we don't dance around and we get
straight to the [__] to the point
straight to the point we don't play no
games it's no funny [__] it's no oh blah
blah blah blah blah it's none of that
it's like hey did you do this how did
this go how did this go blah blah blah
but because people have seen a lot of
people have bad moments on big platforms
nowar they don't want to have one of
those bad afraid to be hip hop they're
afraid to go sit down and talk in the
way that not just hip-hop talks but the
way that black people talk the way that
we talk when we interviewing each other
hey man that's crazy what the [__] you
doing hey man you out hey hey sister
boom boom they afraid to had a
conversation so they would rather go sit
down with someone that has a big
platform that will treat them in a way
that's not to me culturally authentic
then actually have a culturally
authentic and Powerful um conversation
with someone that benefits in the long
run them than that person's platform
which I am not in hip-hop media I'm just
telling you my observations and the
entire hip-hop ecosystem so you can't be
brave enough to rap about like shooting
people on records and all of that stuff
and brave enough to be out in the
streets but not brave enough to go sit
down with somebody that's going to ask
you real questions well I think a couple
of things well one like I've heard
actual like managers label people say
like if someone's at a certain level
doing interviews can only hurt them
right well this is what I would say
probably but I I would also say this
there's also another part of
that another part of that is this inside
of this osystem
I know this very well I worked at TMZ
inside this ecosystem we have to hold
interviewers accountable I agree for
asking questions that aren't substantive
that are clout chasy that are beef
inspiring that are all of that stuff you
have your platform you can ask people
whatever you want to ask them you can do
whatever you want to do but if we're
going to talk about all of these
different responsibilities that we have
we also have to talk about the fact that
there is a way that you're supposed to
conduct an interview when the interview
is about music culture inspiration work
ethic when it's about your past when you
really going to sit down and get a
penetrating interview with an artist or
with someone there's a way that you do
that and if you Veer off into the click
baity clout chasy situation which a lot
of people are doing we have to be honest
about those people too yeah I think like
my approach to interviews really is
like if I'm not fully like there's
people I'll interview who I'm like I'm
familiar with their music but I might
not be like a like a hardcore fan right
yeah so my whole approach is
like trying to figure out who they are
like the Common Ground between me and
this person so we can shoot the [__] and
have like a cool conversation like I I
feel like when I think of like Elliott
and Bot I know that they're going to
have the laptop with all of the notes
and then this year and then on this you
know what I mean and there's certain
artists that I'll have those
conversations with but for the most part
you know it's almost like when I went
and did a I just did a interview NBA
young boy and I was like okay everybody
who talks to this guy treats him like
he's an
alien uh I'm just GNA like just go hang
out with him and shoot trying to say
about Baton Rouge well shout out to you
you're from Baton Rouge right trying to
say about Baton Rouge bro well I just
feel like you know like I just wanted to
like just talk like yo let's just hang
out shoot the [__] like went to
Gravedigger Mountain yeah how was it it
was [__] beautiful you loved it it
was cool you loved it okay okay I I you
ever heard of this site point and shoot
on YouTube yeah he just did a video
about me I watched it yo it's so funny
because uh you you mad no I'm not you
mad at the point shoot BR I DM him and
said the video was really good good job
can I show you the video but that was
passive aggressive no it wasn't it was
it was funny it was let me tell you bro
y'all try to what people don't
understand is I've been wait a minute so
you watched that video yeah I watched so
then you know I went to Gravedigger
Mountain so why did you ask me that
question if you knew the answer cuz I
just cuz I I'm playing games cuz you're
a
troll digital r was so funny cuz uh I'm
I did not realize so I used to live in
Vegas I did radio in Vegas right uh and
I used to DJ a monthly hip-hop showcase
so there was there was a guy named high
high life who used to throw these
showcases and me and my boy Sam with DJ
so we would DJ for like maybe 10 to 15
artists every time this would happen so
if you ever been to like a a rap
showcase local rap showcase one they're
not very busy two they [__] suck to
DJ cuz you're dealing with all these
USBS and back then it was it was a CD
you know so I had no idea that I had
ever encountered that dude sharp prior
to the time I met him and he came and
did my podcast right so it's just funny
that like this guy has this like gotcha
moment M and uh is like trying to talk
down on me cuz like I I I frequented
strip clubs in Las Vegas and I've been
but what this is what I would say it was
funny though no no I actually think that
is really funny I think that dude like
he the video was funny but you tried to
draw them out and get them on your
podcast so you can line them up outside
I know what you're trying to no no Kev
you one of the biggest gangsters you
actually might be caus T you one of the
biggest gangsters in Phoenix you trying
to get them this is what people do see
y'all think I'm too I'm too veteran for
this you hey man I appreciate that good
boom boom boom I love to have you come
over here and then all a sudden you and
your man over here stomp him out n and
and that's good for you because now you
got a headline you have children how
many children you got I have two
children and I I are they old I have an
18-year-old and a 10-year-old so that
changes nothing because the 18y old
would help you stomp out point and shoot
outside of the [__] if you had
babies that would be one thing but you
what you just said was I got another
[__] in the crew that can help me
[__] stomp out point I'm not risking
any charges boom there you go I'm not
risking any felonies I get it for a
video I actually genuinely thought the
video was funny it was I watched all his
videos and I think that like he's
actually really good there's something
to be said that when someone is
obviously [__] with you and joking I
thought it was like all of the stuff he
said about me I genuinely took very
talented you I thought it was like funny
I was like oh that's good cuz like I'm I
have like uh I don't have that big of an
ego I don't really give a [__] like the
way him and I talk to each other me and
my friends talk to each other I'm like
this shit's great what uh what YouTubes
do you watch what YouTube channels do
you I mean I would say most of my
YouTube stuff is very Sports heavy okay
Sports heavy okay um you know I would
say I watch a lot of PFT with like Mike
Florio Chris Sims I watch uh you know
mcafe he's in there every once in a
while all the NBA stuff uh and then I'll
I'll I veered into like uh there's this
political Channel called breaking points
I know that point uh Crystal bill yeah I
like cryst ball I love them because I
can just watch and I watch crystal ball
I watch Rising as well with uh Rob
Rising is amazing on the hill Robbie
Suave they're great dude they're great
so actually those two shows I probably
watch every day in some capacity Just
Clips you know like to catch up on
what's going on and I I think that it's
dope because it seems like they're all
four of the people involved in those two
shows are very levelheaded and they they
give you different perspectives so you
don't ever go on welcome to hood War
Stories no no no no no I can show you my
algorthm if you want to see it now bro
pause do what the [__] did you see that
I'm saying if you want to see my YouTube
did you did you see what he just did he
said I can show you my algorithm if you
want to see it and then he into his
pants bro look what's the first video
what's the first video seual what I tell
who who I don't want to see your
algorithm bro put your algorithm away
it's my YouTube algorithm put your
algorithm away I don't know what y I
don't know why you call it the algorithm
probably because you want it's my
YouTube algorithm like it put your
algorithm away bro [__] not trying to
see your algorithm I see uh the herd I
see PFT yeah I see uh welcome to hood
War I'll go to welcome to hood War
[__] uh and uh ooo um MSNBC Dan LeBar
so I got I got I don't have as much
other the sports stuff I got a lot of it
right I got but it's all it's very
specific with me so it's LSU football oh
yeah you know what I'm saying it's LSU
football so it's not necessarily I have
a lot of sports stuff on there but it's
specific because I saw myself sifting
through a lot of [__] Sports topics I
didn't give a [__] about right but it's
Saints LSU football very direct sports
stuff like five different LSU football
channels Off the Bench my favorite one
Power Hour LSU [__] uh after further
review there's a show like that for the
Suns I watch called tiger bait there's
this phnx Sports podcast I watch on
YouTube like at the end of every game
they go live and it's and then you sit
down and watch it Kik can't understand
it she comes in and she goes yo why are
you just watch the game why are you
going to sit down and then watch two
hours of somebody talking about the game
that you just watched and I just pause
the TV and I go my wife says the same
thing I'll just pause the TV and I go
you want to be in this or
not cool boom let me watch my [__] let
me watch my [__] let me play the game I
come back all the way from uh [__]
working on the road I'm doing CNN or
something like that I sit down I got the
controller when I have the controller
okay Kev and Spider-Man is swinging
[__] I am Spider-Man I'm swinging
around New York I'm helping people I'm
saving people I'm going on missions bro
just last week no no [__] I beat
Scorpion I beat craving a hunter I beat
[__] Sandman I beat Venom not
Spider-Man me I did it okay I beat I
beat all of these people I saved
Spiderman 2 Spider-Man 2 I saved New
York I saved it when I come home let me
play the game do you ever buy video
games and you're mad cuz you don't have
time to play them wrong that's my life I
buy all the games and I never play them
cuz
lie you could make time to save people
if you really cared about it but the
problem is that you got to listen to
Shoreline Mafia and the rest of the
underground which by the way I'm not
dissing them I [__] with them hard to
ogz shout out toine the rest of the the
underground people you got to listen to
Too Much hip-hop see I don't listen to
as much hip-hop as you I'm g go to my
hip-hop right now I'm g go to my title
because Jay-Z tell me to buy to buy a
title and then after I got title and got
used to title he sold it he sold it to
white people um Verizon bought it right
did Verizon by title I think so yeah is
that true yeah oh but uh so my [__] like
literally the [__] that I'm on like my
playlist it's all old [__] bro yeah I
think mine I I'm not listening to No
much of that new [__] so I age so I've
heard these songs so I don't have to
like but you have to be up on hip-hop
yeah so you don't have time to save New
York the new [__] I love is is
uh so I I I knew who Dave was for a long
time but I never Dave who from the UK so
Dave and Central C put a EPL called
Split Decision which was my second
favorite project from last year but I
dived into this guy Dave and his
discography he's so good you like him
like Dave Dave is like an elite level
rapper where's he from he's from the UK
I'm not [__] with him he's [__]
fire yeah see he's got some of the more
most vulnerable rap songs I've ever
heard in my life that's Cactus T that's
Cactus T right there uh I will tell you
one new group that I like these guys out
of New York they're called 41 they're
fire shout out I've had them on twice
Jen Carter Kyle Rich bro Jen Carter is
crazy bro no she's fire and they're cool
as [__] Jen Carter is crazy bro I'm I
supposed to be listening to that [__]
ptst from the sound of the side how can
I see what I what what I listen to so I
got this what I got on here I got Dua I
got Domino remember him of course get
those Jam is about to slam I got beanie
seagull I got victory which I guess I'm
not supposed to be listening to that
now Puff Daddy oh [__] oh [__] well I
still listen to that [__] [__] that I
got uh flip side be seag oh my God bro
beanie seagull freeway that's actually
freeway and PD crack um so my my
playlist my playlist on here though is I
show you my hip-hop playlist this is my
hip-hop playlist run in The Far Side 93
till infin till Infinity infiny Sean
infy 93 until Infinity shout out to the
Sean fantasy yeah which is the greatest
hip-hop song ever made disagree it was
okay Cactus te uh hey I disagree Mass
Appeal Electric Relaxation SP so this is
like a playlist you put together yeah
this is my [__] shook W I wish I had see
I don't have a playlist like that Me by
Big Sugar Hill I'll just hit search and
like whatever I feel like listening to I
do the same thing boom I do that I do
that too but I do have some playlist
that I have to have and then Spotify has
a 2010s playlist that they've curated
for me that is fire it's like all 2010
[__] that I like title title well
Spotify is great Spotify is shout out to
you could go listen to Higher Learning
on Spotify excl listen Higher Learning
the podcast on Spotify Spotify is great
I I lo I use title for a lot of music
stuff Spotify is amazing it's it's great
I use title for a lot of music stuff
though because title knows me now title
knows me now I give my most of my
podcast from Spotify yeah my 2010's
playlist is gas but yeah I mean I just
and then I'll just download albums you
know like what you download I got jid on
here forever story pray for Paris West
Side gun what side Gun Crazy whole Gro
crazy going back to um going back
to uh Elliot and B do I was loving
Griselda I was [__] with Griselda
listening to a lot of they had the New
Year's interview and then I became a
giselda [__] fan love Griselda love
them love Griselda but I love everybody
I love the people that don't get along I
love Griselda I think Freddy is having a
great like Freddy's actually to me
Freddy's of mine yeah he's one of my
best friends in the world so you and
Freddy best friends yes okay that's my
brother brother for real for real y you
ever been to Sam sof brth yeah of course
okay just making sure chicken wings and
that's the best place to throw money at
strippers because I listen not for mean
reasons obviously listen what you just
said listen let me tell you how you're a
misogynist yeah because I because when
you throw the money at Sam's halfof bra
it's kind of like feeding Birds okay for
wow it's true though it's true wo cuz
anybody who's on the stage has a right
to the dollar whoa Cactus te let me tell
you something you throw money at
strippers I throw it in the air I throw
money to strippers because Fu I accept
them and their humanity and what they
are I throw money to them so do to help
no no no no no you said what you meant
stand on it Cactus T what you said was
you throw money at strippers at them I
throw money to strippers sometimes I
don't throw it sometimes I put it in an
envelope and hand them to and say most
people in the world you will not find
another higher connoisseur of these
establishments other than myself I
rarely go but when I but when I do go
when I say rarely I mean like once a
year but when I do go maybe not even
that but when I when I do go I throw the
money to them hand it off like a [__]
baton cuz I want them to live their
dreams Cactus sir I am very very
integrated in the strip club culture I
very very aware I'm friends with a lot
of strippers what's your budget for a
strip club night what's a good
personally me yeah what's a blle Kev
night it depends on where I'm going okay
so uh if I was in Arizona in my Heyday
like Jaguars which is like the best drip
Club on the west coast jag wires yeah
Jags Jags is the best strip club on the
west coast anybody who's gone will tell
you that all the rappers I take there
say the same thing Jag wies Jags like
jaguar yeah Jaguar uh so I kind of like
you know I just kind of
like I want to say like like it was kind
of like my spot so I would go in there
I'd get my chicken wings I get my
[__] shrimp tacos I get my cabana can
I tell you can I tell quick this is
actually a very precious moment like
there are rare times when you're talking
to someone and you can see the wheels of
their brain are taking them back to a
time where they've legitimately have
Good times yes to a place where they
legitimately like like like Kev started
talking about jaguares and he goes
yeah it's a good place but it wasn't
even like a good place for the reasons
that you like like not even no I get it
it was a good places cuz there are
certain places even naked women are no
naked women where the Ambiance is it's
the Ambiance it's the food the time in
your life is right time in my life and
like for me I would rather I'm a I'm a
like Dive Bar kind of guy or a strip
club kind of guy like I'd rather not be
at a nightclub I mean I own a nightclub
in Scottsdale right so like I shots of
the nightclub game [__] does very
well I love I'm DJing at nightclubs you
know but I'm not going to a nightclub
unless I'm DJing right it's not your
thing like I don't want to go hang out
at the club because I I don't know if
it's really ever been my thing to be
honest I'd rather go to a die bar or go
to a strip club where we could just
chill have a little convo over some
[__] drinks maybe order some food so
this is my thing about the
club and this is my thing right I'm from
a different club culture right when I
was in Louisiana we dress up we go to
the club we dress up like we going to
church we go to Club upscale we go to
they used to be like that too go to Club
upscale we go to they strictly forced
dress code strictly enforced dress code
right we go to we go to there we go to
uh the NTI we go to a perfect 10 party
shout out to TJ Mike everybody out there
that was throwing party shout out to all
of them we go to the parties and we go
there all dressed up but when we leave
that [__] we are dripping wet
with sweat yeah we dancing you enjoy
yourself you know them old movies where
you see a juk joint right and the people
in there and there beads of sweat coming
off their they sweat and it's a man he
got a his hand on a woman like that and
they grinding and all of that stuff all
that [__] out you know we that's what we
were doing we were ah uh like the Back
That Ass Up come on and like the whole
[__] club lose their I couldn't even
imagine being alive when back that ass
at first came out my God but it was a
couple of joints that you would just
drop by the way and just go crazy but
argument might be you know that's an
argument for best rap song ever could be
um definitely the most best club song
ever could be definitely best club song
ever so like then you get to La and they
don't have none of that that's not how
the clubs are the clubs in LA are uh
musical
museums I think there was probably a a a
time where they were more like that but
I don't remember it but like the clubs
in La were are musical museums like
they're music playing and you're looking
at pretty pictures all around I mean
people are turning up a little bit you
might get a shoulder shimmy or something
like that so I [__] with that and that's
okay but if I'm goingon to do that I
would rather go to a place where I can
hear somebody talking over the music AG
so the music is playing we all chilling
we drinking we having a what what's your
Drinker Choice uh it's it's changed over
the years these days if I'm not trying
to lose weight and be fat uh I always
just get a Corona I like a whiskey sour
and so I'll drink one or tequila on the
Rocks tequila so I'll drink one right
and if I can hear you talking we can all
have a we was I was at a party last
night and it was about it was for the
black Oscar contenders of this year
shout out to Ava and I'm going get like
50 shout outs in this [__] I don't give
a [__] so like we so we all having it
and we're just talking and we're dancing
some people are dancing that's what I
like I'm older yeah no I just think that
like like you said like for me I'd
rather go to a bar or I'd rather the
strip club is Just Like Home to me I
feel like what's your favorite movie
with an all black cast with an all black
cast you can't Friday
Friday Cactus T fake answer how's that a
fake answer F but it's it's the true
answer it's it nope it's nope it's too
much who's your favorite rapper Jay-Z
nah I didn't say JayZ no but what I'm
saying is nope you can't say Friday you
can't you go to go I'm challenging you
to go deeper than that I'm challenging
you go deeper than Friday would city of
God count no no okay I
mean you Wy [__] you maybe but
not really kind of but no moonight would
say moonlight now now you're trying to
be woke love Moonlight I love it too
it's [__] A Perfect movie great movie
A Perfect movie try to get Charlamagne
to watch it a perfect movie um Perfect
movie Perfect movie movie La La Land
better but but like yeah I can't see I I
can't I can't watch anything with
singing in it oh you don't like musicals
no I can't do it I can't do it my wife
was telling me so last night we went and
what's her favorite musical I don't know
[__] probably [__] little mermaid or
some [__] last night uh went to the
movies with my family her and my other
son that's 10 went and saw Wonka I went
and saw ironclaw with my 18-year-old
yeah that's look [__] it's a [__] sad
movie dude Kev like you wanted to bond
with him you wanted him to know the mean
in the family which is why you took to
see that cuz that movie well no me and
my son are hardcore wrestling fans yeah
as I am I'm the number one voice in
wrestling
media are you yeah that's new I'm the
number one voice in wrestling media
that's not true go to my Twitter are you
are you trolling Rosenberg go to my
Twitter is that what it says yeah I'm
the number one voice in I don't think
I'm hipped to why you're saying that so
is it like when Andrew SCH said he was
the number one voice in MMA media and
was trolling the other guy with the
glasses I don't know what you're talking
about as far as that's control y I
didn't know that well congrats I'll see
you a Royal Rumble in a couple weeks I
am and it's been discussed this is not
this is not me just saying this I've
been put over I've been put over who put
you over a couple different people you
don't need to know that I've like I've
been put over oh you know what I'm
saying I'm do you watch wrestling though
serious question I am over as [__] do
you actually watch though no you don't
of course I watch wrestling oh okay of
course I watch wrestling did you watch
Raw last night I haven't uh I was at the
movies see what I'm saying this is what
I'm talking about when I'm talking about
white people you're asking me if I watch
wrestling last night what was I doing
watching [__] raw I was watching but
I was watching Punk and then you're
going Tow and you're going to come back
and you're going to say you didn't even
watch Raw last night I watch Iron Claw
you didn't even watch it about the Von
Erics I watched ironclaw mhm about the
Von Erics yeah tell what's your what's
your favorite match from Jimmy Superfly
snooker two you didn't answer it because
you don't know wrestling like I know
wrestling that's before my time but uh I
was joking I want to say was it no it
wasn't Jimmy was it was Jimmy Superfly
I'm trying to think what was
WrestleMania was it two or three where
[__] macho man I don't think that was
against Jimmy super Superfly you know
what I'll be honest with you all just
aside I'm not good at recounting like
individual matches that I love I have
individual matches that I love to me me
there are certain matches that I do love
there's certain matches that I love too
that I can call out but it's more story
lines it's more specific uh moments it's
Hill turns like my favorite wrestler of
the last 10 years uh this is before he
passed everyone knew this but I love
Bray you love who Bray Wyatt Bray Wy was
my guy dude dude he was my guy for some
reason I thought you said Ray and then
I'm like pass no Bray yeah Bray was that
[__] dude I felt like he was so
mismanaged and he he should have been
the guy to beat [__] Undertaker not
Brock the other thing the other thing
that that is tough about being the
number one voice of pro wrestling and
being such a wrestling fan is such a
hard life on the guys man and the ladies
so you're like it's going to be a lot of
tragedy if you're a huge wrestling fan
because watching did you watch ironclaw
I did that watching that movie you're
like damn like wrestling literally like
destroyed that's some different [__] I
like I won't shout out to Kevin von Eric
and like at the end of the ironclaw not
to not to um see a picture of his family
see a picture of his family I couldn't
have been happier for him me too man cuz
the whole movie you're just you're just
feel for him yeah I do not want anyone
to
think it's not too far off though I was
going to say that the von Eric family
represents the typical wrestling
family's trajectory but I mean there's a
lot of Carnage and a lot of tragedy but
that is man God bless Kevin von Eric
that
is that is next level dude bro that's
insane and look I've seen this before I
know um in my own life right now you
know all my dad my my dad and all his
brothers pass away my my father like
literally in the last 15 years we lost
all of those guys right so my Uncle Mark
died uh then my dad died then my Uncle
Milton died excuse me my Uncle Mark died
my Uncle Milton died my dad died my
Uncle Ray died nobody touched 70 right
so the movie hit me in a different way
at this time because I'm looking at it
and I'm thinking about Brotherhood bonds
a whole line of family what it meant for
my Uncle Ray who just passed away a
couple of weeks ago to be the last of
his brothers and to know that all of
those guys are gone you know he didn't
even make it a year and a half two years
after my father passed away I'm not sure
how much he wanted to be here right um
after all of that stuff and like if you
if you from B Rouge or other places like
that you know situations where he didn't
got killed his brother didn't got killed
[__] his mama got killed everybody so
it's not like I don't know tragic
situations like that when it happened to
them in the way that they happened to
them just the
bizarre hyper tragic nature of all of it
it gives it this
weird almost spiritual through line and
you try to wonder when you're watching a
movie or you're injesting a story like
that you you wonder like what's the
point like what is like what what did
all of that tragedy mean there has to be
a meaning for someone to lose one kid
from uh uh getting electrocuted another
kid from uh suicide another kid from SU
suicide another kid had
gastroenteritis yeah his uh his
intestines I think three sons committed
suicide I think it was Carrie Michael
and um and the youngest one so three
suicides and then all you you wonder
these you know especially as they get
older even like Carrie like losing his
leg well done in the movie Carri losing
his just freak accident after freak
accident it's just a a crazy crazy crazy
story great movie though everybody
should go check Zack eon's [__]
jacked he's big I'm like bro what did he
what I want to know like that's like
committing to a role because he turned
into like a
[__] John Cena level yeah yoked ass
[__] not big got big I mean you know